- No offense Jamie, you look very nice,
but you might have my favorite outfit on
that anyone's worn on this show,
this is so cute.
- Okay, holla!
Thank you.
- [Kelly] It's like-
- Thank you so much.
- It's like a reinvention of
"Rhythm Nation," Janet Jackson.
I'm so into it.
- Oh we love Janet, we
thought this would be perfect.
- Oh my God, it's so
awesome, I love your outfit,
I'm gonna be talking
about it for a minute.
Meet Jamie, have y'all ever met?
- Yes, no, no,
it's our first time.
- No, no, big fan.
- Nice to meet you.
- Yeah.
- All right, we're just
bringing people together
here at the show.
- Yeah, I love it.
- Well, do you like dulse?
Have you ever had dulse?
This is yours.
- I've never had.
- [Kelly] Look at her.
(audience laughs)
- I'm good. I'm from Brooklyn.
- "I'm good." She says.
- I'm a very honest person.
So if I don't like it,
I'm gonna let you know.
- It's good. It's good
- All right, we'll see.
- And look, I like all
food, like it's good.
- My friends know I'm so
picky, my whole family.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
Yeah, I really like everything,
but Brussels sprouts, yeah.
- [Jamie] She likes it.
- [Kelly] It's good (beep).
(all laughing)
She was like, "Mm tastes just like honey!"
- Thank you so much.
- Oh my God wait, we didn't want Dominique
to feel like Brooklyn
wasn't represented as well.
So, could we bring out
some Brooklyn style pizza?
(audience cheering)
- Yeah!
- No we're talking.
- We like Brooklyn style pizza.
- I mean,
- Check this out.
- I can't vouch for it
cause we are in Los Angeles.
- Dang!
Okay I'm just saying like,
I'm just gonna take a bite.
- Do I just dig in? Yeah!
- Yeah, look I'm a good host.
Watch, you want this one?
You were going for it.
- I was gonna go for it.
- So I'm gonna let you have it okay.
- Oh my goodness.
- Look at that!
Wait, I'm gonna give you
this one 'cause you're-
- [Jamie] That is big.
- [Kelly] There we go.
- [Jamie] I'll go with chili flakes.
- Oh my God, I like usually the parmesan.
They weren't thinking of me.
Oh no, it's there okay.
I'm gonna try it.
- Really.
- This is good, actually.
- It just kind of feels cold
'cause it's been waiting for a minute
- for you to get out here.
- But you know that pizza is good
when it's cold and it's still good.
- Still good.
- It is.
- it's the night you
drink, you order pizza,
you shouldn't have, but then
you wake up the next morning,
You're like, it's still good.
- It's still good, leftover pizza, yeah.